Buuut CAn YoU do ThIS?
oh wow I bet you can't
ooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
We're travelling to okinawa, which is this uh.
island south of Japan between Thailand(Should be Taiwan ~.~) and Japan. So it should be nice. It should be hot except it's going to rain
Damn it
The Queen has been there
Hooray we've been in Japan
two two weeks now, and we're staying two more weeks, for everyone asking. Okay. There's your answer
("A bunch of School Kids" screaming in background)
(Felix)
A bunch of school kids.
We're here, it's raining
We also couldn't rent a car because we are not allowed to drive here
Probably could have guessed that but we rented cars in another country before and it's never been an issue
Our place is kind of in the middle of nowhere
But it's nice. It looks pretty
I think
(Me too! It's VeRy NiCe)
[Music]
Since weather is bad we decided to go to
the main road, I don't know very busy very touristy
Anytime we leave Tokyo it's so easy to get around in Tokyo. Oh my god. That's a pufferfish
But anytime you leave Tokyo it's immediately so difficult, I can't call a taxi and all this stuff
We're here
Thank you, the signature move everyone. I don't know what's going on apparently. This is like a famous icecream
It's a flavor
Purple purple flavor oh my god.
Lil Pump would love this ice cream
Japan being its Japan usual
We've been seeing these everywhere
Here, apparently they are to protect your house. Oh
These are cute. Hey Marzia
Yeah, this is underwear
[Marzia] No
No way. [Felix] You know this is underwear
I'm tired. Where are you going? This is underwear.
Hey Marzia, this is me when I get demonetized
You guys recognize these huh you remember that Zaku
wanna get some Evangelion sake?
That's pretty cool
Got that one okay, that's kind of creepy
What is this?Snake drinks?
Become lucky with money
Marzia I need this
Pikachu
Go Pikachu!
Don't care about you Mario get out of here
The amount of sweets I'm having here in Japan
You want some
All right, we're back. I'm enjoying some of the sake, but I bought earlier
We kind of had a strange day because we because of the weather and the fact that we couldn't rent a car our planes
That sort of change, but it's supposed to be
Beautiful weather tomorrow, so we're hoping for the better
the best
There's something. I haven't told you guys
Yeah, okay sure I was gonna dye it back to my old color
This is not my color. This is just the I guess they try to match the beard mom if you're watching
I should have listened, but this is how I look like now so you guys better be nice about it. Okay? (Yeah sure, the subreddit is just going to be pretty normal this week xD)
Good morning today's a lot prettier outside very nice. We're gonna. We're gonna. Go to a beach now and
Do what you do at a beach?
What do you do at a beach the water have that turquoise?
beautiful
Smells doesn't it
Did you fart since we don't have a car we got to do a 20 minute hike no big deal. It's fine. We're heading like
To the end over there we have already discovered the biggest bugs. I have ever seen in my life
They were really big. I'm actually scared as well 20 minute hike let's go. They're so big and
As soon as you go near then they go kick and fly in random directions
Marzia is just running. She's like I'm done
I've never seen her run like this
And there's a lot of stray cats on this beach
You probably can't hear me because of the wind let's see how cold the water is
That's pretty nice (Just like your haircut)
Going for lunch here looks interesting. This is so cool
In case you're wondering the food was really good. There's just cats everywhere here
I see it there. There it is x2 You see that
They are so big so since we don't have a car. We have to walk through this minefield. What do they call?
Grasshoppers could jump out at any moment
A lot of people have been asking why I'm not vlogging
Well, I'm in Japan and the reason why is because I don't want to draw more attention to us
Then we already are we sort of get recognized way more this time around couple dozen times a day sometimes
And it's it's fine. I think I've reached this point where I'm like PewDiePie is so popular
I can't tell the difference if it's a
Fan or just someone that thinks I'm famous like if someone is a fan and watch my videos
I'm happy to take a picture
But if if I notice that it's just someone that wants me as like in their photo because they think I'm famous I'm almost like
Alright people always like oh, you're famous so you have to just deal with this
But people are so rude as well like it's so many people are just straight up rude like taking pictures of us
Like we can clearly see you. It's so obvious we caught them then then they'll go like oh
Oh, sorry
Can we take a picture and as I yeah great like you didn't already get one like usually we get recognized like and we're used
to being recognized
But we also really like Japan because we don't get recognized all the time and this time it's been so different that we're like
Shit but yeah, Okinawa here, it is the vlog
We're going to check out the boat tour like
You can see fishes and stuff. I know I want fishes as much as you do. I look like Tintin
I can't get over it. It's so bad. How did I end up like this? (Self realization is the most humble human trait afterall)
That was really fun that was really cool. They were so sweet that
Family, I guess hey Marcia. Do you see any reptiles around here? No cuz I see the zucc
In the middle of nowhere machine vending machine hard : Park
She could wash away, thank you that can't be oh my god. It's real
What are you doing here he says here on the road oh
I'm sorry
Where'd you get bit? *On my legs* Oh, no, The one thing [that's] good about being me is that mosquitoes don't bite me cuz I'm like
THE ZUCC
Scared happy
Have you seen that video where there's a
Reptile running away in the beach, and then snakes just come out of the rocks like 20 snakes
They look like this beach konichiwa if the earth isn't flat then explain this
Honestly it's so peaceful
We've been sort of cursing the fact that we couldn't get a car, but honestly just walking around has been so nice
My favorite part of the trip. We're leaving tomorrow actually
You were a quick trip as always their life of a YouTuber you gotta keep making videos
Not a youtuber
Poodipie, no everyone knows. They work ahead of schedule. I don't do that shit dog. This is my favorite sign. I've seen so far
Gave myself a lil trim feel like I needed to
Proportion my face a little bit. Leave a comment right now. What you think?
Thank you very much for the nice comment now
Um we're going back home today, so I'm not gonna vlog
But I want to show my setup in Tokyo and how that looks like so
Alright, we're back
This is how my setup look at it looks like it's really just a small bedroom
With a room divider. I was so worried that it was gonna be too loud with neighbors
But no one has complained yet, so there we go. I got my origin
Computer the smaller one which is so convenient that I could just put it in my luggage
I got this camera while I was here because mine broke
But it works pretty well got the cushions just to make the acoustics a little better
It's not perfect, but it does the job and I'm just really glad I can
Make videos while traveling so easily
I'm so thankful that I'm able to make videos while I'm in Tokyo cuz we're really having a really great time
It's so cool to...
Don't know it's experience what we always thought we could do with YouTube because like I can upload videos from anywhere technically
But now we're actually putting it to the test, and it's so cool to see that it works, so
Anyway, thanks for watching this vlog leave a like if you enjoyed and as always
Here's a little kissy